hello and welcome to this video playing
mohammed ng6 going for a little bit of a
for now I just want some other positions
for a change we should be five is very
very decent choice I think this might be
even objectively better and then deform
even though this is these kind of things
are tough to say okay isn't that the
position where white can go for this
gambit stuff with beef form looks a
little bit market
but I think after beat eggs ok so what
to do here not sure about all this maybe
also a 3 before and not sure ok this I
like b5 i have 90 x 2 B 3 to be
difficult to maintain c5
that's a very good position for what I
don't I don't see how he keeps this pawn
on c5
it's a pawn ok so c3 fixing it and
taking it next I don't think you can
prevent that look a for Queenie to a
moose to attack the pawn and he has no
way to defend it ok so we need to maybe
on f5 I'm going to play a 30 porn on e4
would always basically kill this night
only seven I can take with the Queen as
well
Trading Queens isn't so bad and you can
only avoid it with moose that look
awkward yeah like this ok so how to do a
chin gain some space
Jim a 7 was a weakness but a six isn't
any better
h5m wants to go to g6 wants to go to F
forum
yeah how to keep perfect control and
nights if Ivan I think I can so should
just do that night on f4 is not not yet
threatening anything so we gives me the
d far okay
okay so
yeah what's the deal here any
counterplay i mean i can probably just
take stuff i mean i'm cautious yeah I've
bought so many positions where I mean it
was like a complete one way street and
then I'm losing to some some Hail Mary
last kind of hope attack they don't want
to have this happen again
edgy for has attacked and if he goes
green g62 true took to a cover it means
that the night cannot move the e7 night
and he wanted to go on a g6 to our form
yeah if he goes g3 I'll just take this
choice ok so then what I have to to
check is the back rank definitely
shouldn't fall to some background trick
ok so maybe f3 or something
is not no no real threat okay
I can also check here and some 26 matter
no looks time morning looks like it
should win but check again i don't feel
like i did this perfectly 'if I've is
also hanging check
check black for fits on a time yeah it's
also with bishop t fords going to be
made okay so yeah I'm coming challenge
anyway so okay so here I took and 23 I'm
not completely sure or all this I'm kind
of making things up here what I'm pretty
sure about though is that 26 is wrong I
think you should go a 5m and go for a
full block of the queenside after which
my ideas c3 before later now I think you
should do that after this and a 5 it's
already a little bit awkward as I'm
getting some pressure on the queenside
now and I hear what is bad and I'm I'm a
lot better up to be five maybe it's
probably very tough to get to still have
something playable the engine gives wide
upon which is probably a fair assessment
as I members and winning a pawn problem
yeah guarantee simply cannot save the
point that c4 is also good but yeah why
just has an enormous pressure on all
those pawns it's technically a win but
you still have to do it just hope I
didn't screw it up to Italy I doubt it
that's actually the best move check okay
so i will always plus five so check it
it to anything completely stupid check
NTM check to Bishop g7 I'm going to meet
in a couple of moose yeah the key moment
is already here and queen d 6 is a is a
mistake he has to go a five and prevent
me from going a five and here it's not
easy for white I mean I can put a night
on see forward from there it's not easy
to make progress at all and here this is
some not comfortable probably best is
Ruby aid and here I have a little
something and I can maybe take and put a
rope here there are ideas on those pawns
like here here possibly before the
problem for black little bit is that
currently this Bishop is very passive
and this night only seven that's not so
ID and it looked at covered squares so
white is a little bit better it's not
not clear how much it is but why it
definitely has a somewhat more
comfortable position but after b5 it is
just it's just too bad because I'm
threatening that b3 and just basically
win the opponent it's impossible to
cover yeah shows us some ideas of the
Bishop b5 so Sonja in this game okay
thanks for watching